uber agrees to buy
alcohol delivery service drizzly
for 1.1 billion okay 1.1 billion dollars
uber agrees to buy them founded in 2012
drizzly has become the leading on-demand
alcohol delivery service in us and is
available in 1400 cities
the purchase could help drive people to
see uber's app more often uber eats
has been a key segment to uber's
business and the covenant pandemic which
has dramatically reduced
the number of people leaving their homes
during the this time during this time
our business has been uh seen growth
extraordinary rates uber seo dara said
on cnbc drizzly said it had more than
300
growth uh this past year the deal is
expected to close within the first half
of 2021 uber said it anticipates that
more than 90 of the consideration
to be paid to drizzly shareholders will
consist of shares of uber common stock
and the balance will be in cash
so a 90 10 split is what they're doing
at the same time uber has uh
offloaded some of its uh more
cost-eating transportation segments the
company last may
transferred its electric bike and
scooter business jumped to lime
uber also sold itself driving unit
advanced technology group to its startup
competitors
aurora innovation on december 7th at a
valuation of 4 billion at the same time
so what are your thoughts about this
drizzly and 1.1 billion
purchased by uber so yeah this is i'm
glad that you started with this so
if there's anybody that can speak about
the advantages of using uber it's the
guy that hasn't had a car in freaking 10
years
so well right now i'm carpooling with my
mom for the next week until i move into
my apartment shout out to your mom
coolest mom out there she's cool she's
cool she's groovy i feel like i'm 17
years
old again you know carpooling my mom um
but i uber everywhere
and let's talk about what uber is
focusing on and what uber is
basically deleting from their um
focus so you got uber by the way we
tried to take an uber
package the other day people are coming
in town we need to give them their keys
yeah
seven people who work at valuetainment
couldn't figure out how to order an
uber package so in uber here's what you
have you can take an uber all right i
need to go
to my friend's house i'm taking an uber
you can go uber eats
right you want to order in food you're
staying in everyone's ear and covered
you're ordering in
you got uber packages hey uh clarissa uh
leo they just got in town we got to give
them their keys
send them the keys in a package you
don't have to go drive over there wink
wink at mario
they'll send them the package that's
easy they got uber groceries so they're
competing with the insta carts of the
world and now
they're basically saying look we got
liquor too so they're basically saying
listen work at home
eat at home drink at home party at home
everywhere you need to go just we got
you uber what do they not have thank you
buddy move that move that out of there
thank you
it was cutting mario's head off there we
want to make sure we got to see mario
this is actually pretty interesting they
stopped their e-bike
um focus their they stop their
self driving component yep
and this i had to reread this like three
times the flying
taxi unit what the hell's that
they were they they announced it was
selling their flying
taxi business called elevate was that
was that is that am i reading that
correctly flying cars
yeah what is this back to the future
this is gonna happen i mean what do you
think's gonna end up happening i mean i
don't know i feel like elon musk is
gonna take over that business who knows
what that but
this just this move with drizzly
specifically for a billion bucks 90
shares 10 cash makes complete sense with
their focus of
you know staying at home ordering in
ordering packages getting your liquor
so that's my taking what are your
thoughts so first of all
just so you know during the pandemic at
the peak of the pandemic in
april do you know how much the sales of
drizzly was up
you guys know what do you what do you
think it was up during april may
how high do you think their stock went
up sales coming in sales is coming in
percentage-wise or percentage-wise 135
percent
700 to 800 percent you took the under
it's how high they were so explain that
why do you think that leveled
around 350 350 for the rest of the year
pretty much and you you heard
you know in this article i'm reading it
says you know they've seen growth of you
know growth of 300
etc etc so why well people stayed home
and they had drinks they're depressed
let me get a drink let me get a second
one let me get a third one and then boom
let me order let me order let me order
easy access you know i can just go get
it it's gonna come to me
and uh so you know that showed
what direction potentially the world is
going to
so uber's sitting there saying wait if
people are ordering liquor the way they
are right now why don't we own that
business
are they assuming there's going to be
another pandemic are they assuming it's
going to be more work from home are they
assuming this the direction that things
going to go yeah
working from home et cetera i don't know
but they
definitely made the right move this is a
very very smart strategic uh
uh purchase that they made and i think
this is gonna be benefiting uber
uh in a big way for a very long time
this isn't gonna be a small business
here
this 1.1 billion dollar business that
they bought
look at this 1.1 billion dollar business
how quickly it's gonna end up being a 20
30 billion dollar business oh you think
so oh
buddy you know listen alcohol
ain't going away you know breakups are
not going away depression is not going
away people being
celebration bad celebration down
birthdays birthdays it's not going away
we're trying to convert people to
drinking soy yes
but drizzly look for my new line of soy
soy-based alcohol
that's coming out it'll be on the
valuetainment shop check that out at
valuetainmentstore.com
what paul do you have any opinions on
drizzly let's see what paul wants to say
about drizzly
i do i do think it's a good idea um
anything deep tell us outside of a good
idea do you have any deep thoughts on
this topic
i do think it's a good idea guys that's
paul's cards
i don't think i have anything deep on
drizzly it's not a you tell me
you've been prepared they're maximizing
you just had your moment right there
here's the freaking bottom line you have
the choice of ordering liquor
into your house the couch or going to
the freaking gecko we all know where
you're going you're going to the bar
you're going to get go you're not a stay
at home and drink kind of
yeah look you go hit the streets i think
it all depends on what state you're
living in i think in certain states it's
really going to have a huge impact
yeah like places like florida and texas
where places are open
i don't see it having as much of an
impact versus california where
everything's closed yeah i could see
that having a huge impact or if you're
up north in the winter
new york minnesota if it's connecticut i
like that that's a good one you went
deep
good for you so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye